hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen sieht
vorstellung
ihr habt mir jetzt mal die kommentare
geschrieben jahren auch ruhig so weiter
mit den zieht vorstellung wenn er was
witziges dabei ist dann macht es einfach
und noch ab und zu vielleicht noch mal
ein paar landschaften zwar bis heute
wieder ein immens witzigen sieht für
euch ja da werdet ihr wahrscheinlich
alle drüber lachen wenn ihr einen
komischen humor habt also treten uns
eine neue welt der name ist local
natives ja das ist ein sehr guter name
ich mach das mal ganz egal
das ist der sieht dass hier also das
sieht es 146 5 87 17 43
das sieht wurde mir auf meine facebook
pinnwand geschrieben von meiner seite
contractor die und in der beschreibung
ist und wo ihr gleich sonderlings
eingeblendet ihr seht mit meiner seite
da könnt ihr einfach mal vorbeischauen
und zwar lese ich dort die zieht
vorschläge öfter die entweder an meine
seite schreibt als zb bei youtube wenn
ihr so 1000 kommentare sind oder so 1006
übertrieben jedenfalls riesig ist da
öfter noch eine sache wenn viele leute
gesagt hey du bist ja da sind also
komische blumen bei dir nee das ist
einfach nur tropic kraft und das hat nix
mit der welt erstellung zu tun
tropic kraft hat damit nichts zu tun da
sind da nur so ein paar bambus zum
beispiel so ein paar blümchen hier drin
mehr ist da nicht also das ist einfach
das verändert nichts an der welt also
das erste was wir hier haben ist also da
sind wege spot und fliegt halt hier hin
da haben wir hier eine immens geile
nicht schluss sondern so eine art
komische stoff war die macht das mal
kurz so komische licht wachstum ihrer
höhle und jedes detail schon ein
bisschen krass da kann man das
vielleicht mit glas gegen die darüber
bauen oder keine ahnung und das einzig
interessante ist dass da und zwar fliegt
einmal kurz daran vorbei dass und wie
bringst die fallen die ich vorhin
erwähnt habe hier ist eine ganz normale
pyramide denkt ihr gehe ich da rein
was ist das es ist das ist ja hier ist
ein spieler mit china pyromedia das ist
richtig krass ist ein spot mitten in der
pyramide also das hier ist alles ein
bisschen zu geschäft natürlich von sand
aber wenn man sich das mal von oben an
guckt da ist eine pyramide das sind
unter anderem
tnt ist da drin da ist diamant ist da
drin ganz viel eisen ganz viel gold ist
alles drin und jetzt halt wirklich noch
so einen sportler mit einer kiste und
unter anderem auf seiner musik disc na
ja wir können auch aggressionen
reingehen also hier unten haben wir tnt
das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle schon
dass man hier so eine ladung tnt hat
also neuen tnt habt ihr hier drin
dann haben wir hier das ich zähle ich
das gleich mal ist auch dass und hier
ist noch ein diamant drin und zwar haben
jetzt insgesamt neun verrottetes fleisch
vier eisen 4 gold 4 redstone acht seide
eine musik des namens 13 ich dort ist
eine neue ich weiß aber nicht genau
weizen sechs spreng pulver ein sattel 16
knochen und einen diamanten der diamant
ist unwichtig den lassen einfach daten
ein quatsch das herz eines minecraft das
netzkarte zuschaut weint wenn man einen
diamanten fallen lässt aber ich fand's
einfach ganz wichtig dass der da so ist
ich also der seeed wurde mir halt von
einer person namens manolis glaube ich
zugesendet meine facebook-seite und
dafür möchte ich mich echt sehr dort
bedanken weil das ist echt interessant
so was habe ich noch nicht gesehen und
wollte ich euch einfach mal zeigen und
dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
kräftiges sieht in die kommentare
schreiben bewerten nicht vergessen und
so weiter